presque six ans après la signature de
l'accord de vienne
la situation s'est bien dégradée signé
sous le second mandat de barack obama
cet accord n'avait pas les faveurs de
donald trump qui avait décidé d'en
sortir en mai 2018
une décision qui avait généré nombre de
points de discorde entre pays
signataires et qui avait été accompagnée
de sanctions américaines envers l'iran
compromettant de facto les relations
diplomatiques entre washington et
téhéran depuis l'iran s'est affranchi de
certains engagements notamment sur son
stock d'uranium dont le niveau s'établit
largement au dessus du seuil en pause
est arrivé le mois dernier à la maison
blanche
je baille donne à lui promis un retour
dans l'accord et une suppression des
sanctions mais à condition que téhéran
renault avec ses engagements initiaux
les etats-unis vont-ils d'abord lever
les sanctions afin de ramener l'iran à
la table des négociations
non ils doivent d'abord arrêter
d'enrichir de l'uranium
du côté iranien c'est une stratégie de
la surenchère qui est privilégié la
république islamique demande des actes
du côté de l'oncle sam
avant un retour à ses engagements une
décision logique tant le traumatisme
laissé par les sanctions imposées par
donald trump demeure présent et handicap
la vie des iraniens auprès des jeunes et
nous avons entendu de belles paroles et
de promesses mais dans la pratique celle
ci ont été violées les paroles et les
promesses sont inutiles seuls les actes
comptent
si nous voyons un geste en provenance de
l'autre partie alors nous agirons
mais si nous entendons encore des
promesses comme nous ferons ceci ou cela
alors la république islamique ne se
montrera pas satisfaites nous n'allons
pas nous faire avoir comme ce fut le cas
précis d'un arabe
mais ces causes est générale
pour mettre la pression sur
l'administration byden téhéran a fait
part de son intention d'interrompre le
droit aux inspections inopinées de
l'agencé internationale de l'énergie
atomique
une décision qui s'appliquerait dès le
21 février prochain
ce qui contraint les signataires de
l'accord de vienne à se concerter
rapidement pour trouver une issue à une
énième crise le directeur général de l'
aiea a lui proposé de se rendre en iran
samedi afin de trouver une solution
ce serait alors sa deuxième visite dans
le pays la première avait abouti à un
résultat en demi teinte la république
islamique autorisant la visite de deux
sites qui n'abritait plus d'activités
nucléaires depuis des années